se tiene una muestra de 36 manzanas de
la cosecha de tu granja de más de
200.000 manzanas el peso medio de la
muestra es de 112 gramos con una
desviación estándar de la muestra de 40
gramos cuál es la probabilidad de que el
peso medio de todas las manzanas esté en
el rango de 100 a 124 gramos veamos qué
es lo que nos están pidiendo existe una
distribución de todos los pesos de todas
las 200 mil manzanas sumas que tienen
así que la distribución del peso de esta
población sería algo más o menos así
tendrá un peso medio que no sabemos cuál
será este peso medio
y también tendrá una desviación estándar
de la población así que aquí podemos
dibujar la desviación estándar por
encima de la media y aquí la desviación
estándar por debajo de la media y
decimos que esta distancia de acá es la
desviación estándar de la población
desconocemos los valores de ambos
parámetros
esta es la distribución de la población
distribución de la población y sabemos
por vídeos anteriores que podemos estar
tomando muestras repetidamente muestras
de cierto tamaño en este caso serán
muestras de 36 manzanas una y otra vez
obteniendo la media de cada muestra y
graficando la frecuencia de estas medias
y así eventualmente obtendremos algo que
se llama la distribución de muestreo de
la media de la muestra vamos a
escribirlo aquí la distribución de
muestreo
de la media de la muestra
y va a lucir algo así vamos a dibujar un
poquito más grande pues es probable que
usemos esta gráfica un poquito más va a
ser muy parecida a una distribución
normal
va a tener cierta media y esto lo
especificamos dibujando la aquí abajo no
tenga esta es la media de la
distribución de la muestra
y sabemos que la media de la muestra
o que la media de todas las medias va a
dar como resultado la media de toda
nuestra población original así que esto
va a ser igual a la media de nuestra
población y esto también tiene una
desviación estándar así que aquí a lo
mejor está la desviación estándar por
encima de la media
aquí en verdecito y la desviación
estándar por debajo de la media acá
podemos especificar que esta distancia
entonces es la desviación estándar de la
distribución de muestreo de las medias y
sabemos que ésta estará dada o
aproximada ya que para muestras grandes
este es un muy buen indicador
esta va a ser la desviación estándar de
nuestra población
la desviación estándar de la población
dividida entre la raíz cuadrada
y eso lo vimos en unos vídeos anteriores
dividido entre la raíz cuadrada del
número de muestras que hemos tenido para
obtener cada una de estas medias así que
en este ejemplo tenemos una muestra de
36 manzanas por lo que esto va a ser la
raíz cuadrada de 36 así que es la
distribución de muestreo de la media de
la muestra para una muestra de 36
manzanas de esos 36 elementos se obtiene
el promedio y cada una de esas medias es
una muestra en esta distribución de acá
las medias de aquí se están usando para
calcular las muestras o mejor dicho las
cosas que usamos para calcular esas
medias son las muestras de esta
población espero que esto no las haya
confundido esta desviación estándar de
la distribución va a ser la decisión
estándar de esta población
la desviación estándar de la población
dividido entre 6 ya que la raíz cuadrada
de 36 y 6 aunque aún no conocemos este
parámetro de acá y con esto en mente
ahora vamos a enfocarnos en lo que nos
están preguntando realmente nos están
preguntando cuál es la probabilidad de
que el peso medio de todas las manzanas
de estas 200 mil manzanas estén en el
rango de 100 a 124 gramos que este peso
medio se encuentre en el rango de 100 y
124 gramos si algo se encuentra dentro
de este rango de 100 y 124 gramos estará
en 12 de nuestra media de la muestra y
eso que nos están diciendo aquí cuál es
la probabilidad de que éstos se
encuentren dentro de las 12 de nuestra
media de la muestra si tenemos menos 12
nos quedarán 100 y si tenemos más de 12
nos quedará 124 así que lo que nos están
preguntando es cuál es la probabilidad
de que la media de la población
este parámetro desconocido de aquí esté
dentro de 12 de la media de nuestra
muestra 1
ahora si yo les dijera que estoy a 5
metros de ustedes también quiere decir
que ustedes están a 5 metros de mí por
lo que esto es exactamente lo mismo que
decir que la probabilidad de la media de
la muestra
o esté dentro de 12
de la media de la población y me
interesa que comprenden esto si yo les
dijera cuál es la probabilidad de que me
encuentre a 5 metros por delante o por
atrás de ustedes es lo mismo que decir
cuál es la probabilidad de que ustedes
se encuentren a cinco metros por delante
o por atrás de mí es lo mismo que tener
una probabilidad de que si yo estoy
separado 12 metros de ustedes y esta es
la probabilidad de que ustedes se
encuentren separados 12 metros de mí
estamos haciendo exactamente la misma
pregunta y se les puede haber ocurrido
que quizás podrían usar la distribución
de la muestra como la media de la
muestra aunque hay una media que
desconocemos que es lo mismo que este
valor de acá vamos a ponerlo más claro
esto es exactamente lo mismo porque este
valor y este otro valor son lo mismo por
lo que esto es igual a preguntarse cuál
es la probabilidad de que la media de
nuestra muestra esté dentro de 12 de la
media de nuestra distribución de la
muestra pues la probabilidad de que la
media de esta sola muestra que tenemos
esté dentro
12 de esta media de la muestra real y en
este momento quizás su cerebro les esté
diciendo bueno si yo pudiera averiguar
si yo pudiera saber cuántas desviaciones
estándar es está separado de esto podría
usar mi tabla zeta para calcular esta
probabilidad y es exactamente lo que
vamos a hacer pero tenemos una pequeña
complicación aquí no sabemos cuál es la
desviación estándar de la distribución
de muestreo solo sabemos qué es esto de
acá dividido entre 6 pero tampoco
sabemos cuál es esta y lo que vamos a
hacer es tratar de encontrar la mejor
estimación de ésta así que necesitamos
encontrar una buena estimación de este
valor de la desviación estándar de
nuestra población y cuál es el mejor
estimado de esto pues podría ser la
desviación estándar de la muestra ya que
tomamos 36 cosas y tenemos nuestra
distribución de la muestra de 40
vamos a escribirlo de esta manera esto
va a ser aproximadamente igual a la
distribución estándar o la desviación
estándar de la muestra que tenemos que
es 40 encontramos el promedio del peso
de nuestros 36 manzanas que salió de 112
gramos y encontramos que la distancia al
cuadrado de los pesos de las manzanas
dio esto todo esto lo hemos hecho muchas
veces en vídeos anteriores el realizar
todo este proceso nos da como resultado
el obtener esta desviación estándar
igual a 40 que es nuestra mejor
estimación para esto por lo que si esta
es la mejor estimación de esto entonces
la mejor estimación de esto otro día acá
va a ser igual a la desviación estándar
de la muestra dividida en 36 que es
igual a 40 entre 6 que a su vez es igual
y sacamos nuestra calculadora para hacer
la operación 40 entre 6
es igual a 6.67 vamos a redondear loa
6.67
nuestra mejor estimación de la
desviación estándar de la distribución
de muestreo de la media de la muestra es
6.67 así que esta distancia de acá es de
6.67 así que cuántas definiciones
estándares nos darán 12 viendo esta
distribución de acá vamos a dividir 12
en 36 puntos 67 sacamos de nuevo la
calculadora para hacer esta operación 12
entre la respuesta anterior 6.67 lo que
nos da eso significa que estoy usando la
respuesta de la operación anterior y nos
da 1.8 los números nos están resultando
bien esto es muy similar a decir cuál es
la probabilidad de que la media de
nuestra única muestra esté dentro
1.8 desviaciones estándares vamos a
escribir la de esta manera
desviaciones estándares de la media de
la muestra de la media real de nuestra
distribución de muestreo
por otra parte si vemos esta
distribución de aquí dentro de una
desviación estándar de 1.8 puede que nos
lleve más o menos por acá 1.8 por encima
y 1.8 por debajo quedaría por acá por lo
que nos resta preguntarnos cuál es la
probabilidad de que al tomar esta única
muestra de 36 manzanas
caigamos en el espacio que se encuentra
acá en este espacio que estoy subrayando
aquí para calcular esto lo que voy a
hacer es usar nuestra tabla zeta para
calcular esencialmente este espacio de
acá que estoy subrayando en magenta cuál
es la probabilidad de estar 12 por
encima de esto y simplemente duplicarlo
ya que la distribución normal es
simétrica vamos a nuestra tabla z para
encontrar cuál es la probabilidad de
estar entre la media y una desviación
estándar de 1.8 por encima de esta media
1.8 hasta acá y 1.80
es justamente lo que está acá pero hay
que tener mucho cuidado este punto 9 641
nos dice la probabilidad de estas si yo
dibujar aquí una distribución normal así
bonita y ésta fuera nuestra media es el
número de acá nos dice la probabilidad
de estar 1.8 desviaciones estándares por
debajo de la media así que si esto es
1.8 desviaciones estándares hasta acá y
esa es nuestra media esto nos va a dar
esta área de acá toda esta área de aquí
y si yo quiero solamente esta parte de
acá que estoy subrayando el amarillo lo
que necesito hacer es a partir de este
valor de este punto 9 641 tengo que
restarle esto de acá que estoy poniendo
en verde la probabilidad de estar por
debajo de la media y este valor está acá
nuestra probabilidad de estar por debajo
de la media o estar por debajo de la
media +0 desviaciones estándar es por lo
que este valor de aquí es punto 50 toda
esta área
es punto 9 641 por lo que esta área
amarilla que es la diferencia entre
estas dos áreas va a ser igual a punto 9
641 menos punto 5 que es igual a 0.4 641
por lo que esta área de aquí que estoy
indicando aquí en amarillo es punto 4
6-4 10.464 1 vamos a asegurarnos que
esté el valor correcto 4 641 y lo que
necesito hacer para obtener toda esta
área de acá es duplicar este valor
y sacamos una vez más la calculadora
para hacer esto y escribimos
0.4 64 1 por 2 igual punto 92 82 toda
esta área de acá al resaltar en amarillo
es igual a punto 92 82 y aquí hicimos
algo muy bueno recordemos que la
pregunta original era cuál es la
probabilidad de que la media de nuestra
muestra se encuentre dentro de 1.8
desviaciones estándares recordamos que
es 1.8 desviaciones estándar es dentro
de la media de la muestra de la media
real es punto 92 82 esto también nos
dice que hay un punto 92 82 de
probabilidades de que la media real se
encuentre en 12 de la media de la
muestra que medimos eso es genial ya que
por primera vez comenzamos con muy poca
información
comenzamos con sólo una muestra chiquita
y pudimos obtener muchísima información
sobre la muestra a partir de ella y
ahora podemos decir que hay un
porcentaje del
y 2.82 de oportunidad de que la media
real esté dentro de 12 de la media que
medimos que la media real se encuentre
entre 100 y 124 gramos
aunque tengamos un 92 punto 82 por
ciento de confianza de que la media real
va a caer en el rango de 100 a 124 lo
cual yo creo que es genial